Mary Janelle and I are all wives of a
man going through a divorce I've never
struggled with Cody in my marriage as
bad as I am right now I'm at a loss
Robin Brown admits her marriage to Cody
feels like it's on the Rocks following
his split from Christine I'm going
through a divorce just give me a little
time to be sad and angry and go through
this process I I'll get over it I think
living my life every day day to day I
would say it's so much better I think
just because I'm so more grounded in I
just like my I just like me and I like
my life so much better now on Sister
Wives Mary and Robin get emotional
talking about how Christine's choice to
leave the plural marriage has impacted
their individual relationships with Cody
Cody is now questioning me left and
right about things that I thought he
knew about me like he's struggling to
trust everybody around him I'm taking it
really personal
I'm not gonna cry about it because I'm
pissed off as with all relationships you
know whether it's spouses or friends or
family or Sisters You've Got the ups and
downs you just do and it's just a matter
of what your commitment level is
Christine's commitment to Cody ended
last November after 26 years of
spiritual marriage he's only legally wed
to Robin I think that I've been if I
made the decision sooner I might have
left out of anger the timing for me to
leave was just it opened up and
everything became just things fell into
place once I decided to just I kind of
looked at where my life was and before I
decided to leave and I'm like do I
really want to do this for another 10
years I feel so pathetic because I'm the
divorce denier and she's like she is
just clearing the Slate man she is out
of here there's a an emotion that I'm
sensing from her of this Wahoo you know
like I'm out of here
and it's uh made me a little crazy and
Robin who's been called Cody's favorite
wife in the past isn't okay with how
he's acting yes you're going through a
divorce with Christine but you have
marriages that you have to maintain he
still has us and he still has marriages
with us and he still has to fix them and
figure them out and get over his anger
enough to actually interact
appropriately or he's going to ruin
every single one of them we still have
the same goals correct and it's
something that we're sort of having to
put a little bit more like energy effort
into that because we're not seeing each
other quite as much in person and so
um I know that I've got some teammates
and these ladies while the mama fives
sad about Christine leaving she knows
it's what is best for her I've always
wanted her to be happy I've always
wanted her to be happy
she just hasn't seemed happy for a
really long time
yeah
Flash Forward to present day and
Christine's happier than ever love
living in Utah close to my kids it's
been fabulous earlier this month the mom
of six told E.T how much she's changed
for the better that's more like a
personal strength that I feel like I
have more than I've ever felt before
because I was able to make steps for my
future and for my present and so I just
feel more confident as well
I feel like it's a lighter easier
breezier Christine I mean do you feel
like a weight has been lifted off your
shoulders you know what enormous weight
has been lifted
[Music]